RUSSIA'S ALREADY TROUBLED
RELATIONS WITH THE WEST ARE
ABOUT TO GET EVEN MORE
COMPLETED.
BILL?
>> Bill: THANK YOU.
REPORTING IN LONDON.
FROM ASIA, THE PRESIDENT OF
SOUTH KOREA SAYING THAT
SANCTIONS ON NORTH KOREA SIMPLY
WILL NOT BE EASED BASED ON THE
HOPE OF TALKS OVER ITS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM.
THE STATEMENT AIMED AT TAMPING
DOWN CONCERN OVER A REPORTED
OFFER FROM KIM JONG UN THAT
HINTS AT A BREAKTHROUGH ON ONE
OF THE WORLD'S MOST DANGEROUS
MATTERS.
CORRESPONDENT PROJECTS AND
REPORTS TONIGHT AT THE
STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> SENIOR U.S. OFFICIALS AND
WORLD LEADERS ARE DIMINISHING
EXPECTATIONS FOR POSSIBLE
NUCLEAR NEGOTIATIONS WITH
NORTH KOREA.
>> Translator: THIS IS JUST
THE BEGINNING.
I BELIEVE WE ARE NOT YET AT A
SITUATION WHERE WE CAN BE
OPTIMISTIC.
>> SOUTH KOREA'S PRESIDENT SAID
SANCTIONS WILL CONTINUE AGAINST
NORTH KOREA, EVEN AS NORTH AND
SOUTH KOREA MEET NEXT MONTH AT A
CEMETERY OF SECRETARY OF STATE
REX TILLERSON AND STILL PUSHING
COUNTRIES TO CUT OFF TRADE
WITH THE NORTH, AS FOR
NORTH KOREA'S OFFER TO NEGOTIATE
ITS NUCLEAR PROGRAM, SENIOR
OFFICIALS AND ANALYSTS SAY THEY
HAVE SEEM A SUPPORT BEFORE.
>> THIS IS NOT OUR FIRST RODEO.
WE'VE BEEN ON THIS BEFORE.
WE'VE HAD EIGHT INTERNATIONAL
AGREEMENTS WITH NORTH KOREA, ALL
OF WHICH FAILED.
I THINK IT'S GOOD TO BE DEEPLY
SKEPTICAL, ALTHOUGH WE SHOULD
TRY AGAIN.
>> IN THE 1950s, WITH THE HELP
FROM THE SOVIET UNION,
NORTH KOREA BEGAN ITS NUCLEAR
PROGRAM, INSISTING IT WAS
PEACEFUL.
IN 1985, I SIGNED ON TO THE
NUCLEAR NONPROLIFERATION TREATY.
PROMISING NOT TO DEVELOP NUCLEAR
WEAPONS.
BUT BY 1989, SATELLITES
DISCOVERED EVIDENCE OF A WEAPONS
PROGRAM.
>> THE NORTH KOREAN PLAYBOOK
REALLY CONSISTING THROUGH THREE
GENERATIONS IS REALLY A TWO PAGE
PLAYBOOK.
ITS PROVOCATIONS AND THREATS AND
EVEN ATTACKS, AND THEN THE
SECOND PAGE IS CHARM OFFENSIVE.
>> 1994, NORTH KOREA THREATENED
TO WITHDRAW FROM A NONPREFERRED
RATION TREATY.
IN AN AGREEMENT WITH THE U.S.,
PYONGYANG COMMITTED TO FREEZING
IS PLUTONIUM PLUTONIUM WEAPONS
PROGRAM IN EXCHANGE FOR AID.
YEARS LATER, THE U.S. DISCOVERED
EVIDENCE OF WEAPONS DEVELOPMENT.
BY 2002, THE U.S. HAD
NORTH KOREA ADMITTED TO HAVING A
CLANDESTINE NUCLEAR PROGRAM.
THEN NORTH KOREAN LEADER
KIM JONG IL INTERJECTED
INTERNATIONAL INSPECTORS FROM
THE COUNTRY.
MONTHS LATER, HE WITHDREW FROM
THE NONPROLIFERATION TREATY.
YEARS OF NEGOTIATIONS WITH
REGIONAL COUNTRIES FOLLOWED AND
IN 2006, NORTH KOREA DETONATED
ITS FIRST NUCLEAR BOMB.
AS U.S. NEGOTIATES THE SECURITY
ISSUES, THERE ARE ECONOMIC
PRESSURES BETWEEN THE ALLIES.
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S PROPOSED
TARIFF ON STEEL WOULD HIT
SIGNIFICANTLY AND LIKELY
SOUTH KOREAN PRODUCERS.
THE U.S. AND SOUTH KOREA ARE
ALSO RENEGOTIATING THEIR FREE
TRADE AGREEMENT, THE WHEN THE